olá a todos botar a verdade de hoje cria
com o site por um sistema consegue
relaxar
gostava de partilhar convosco algumas
ideias sobretudo nas provocações sobre o
que este dado influências para 5 gente e
preço entenderam que no passado presente
e futuro
a versão conceitual são realidades e se
brinca de 15 nós entendemos nesta área
que é uma área muito nova com força
plena agora o que são tendências e que
são móveis que vão passar e quais são as
facas transformações que estão pra ficar
e por isso mesmo eu queria partilhar
convosco com sabe compartilhar o
consegue ser humano não consegue ser
humano
esse conceito é seguramente muitas
definições e eu consegue pular mais
básica todas fui ao dicionário e
procurei o que o dicionário escrever
sobre o conseg semana é uma micro
primata macho indissociável que tal como
nós mexe tem todos os outros animais
pela faculdade da linguagem e pelo sobre
o desenvolvimento intelectual
a questão é que nós todos temos uma
abordagem muito própria sobre o que
sabemos que somos e como vivemos com os
outros e claramente temos uma distinção
entre aquilo que é o conceito ea
realidade e esse foi só uma das
dimensões quase só que procurando muito
mais há muitas outras dimensões que
vocês podem encontrar a verdade é que me
pareceu sempre um crente hora e tudo
aquilo que encontramos isso é que fazer
muito mais sentido se eu começasse a
procurar as pessoas à minha volta em que
as pessoas acham que somos ea forma como
interage e então se me perguntar algumas
direções família amigos e vou usar aqui
para ler algumas das dimensões que os
professores no exemplo é do joão
o joão tem sete eu vou entrar na escola
eles com muito orgulho uma coisa é ter
aprendido um pouco tempo que e eu acho
que uma pessoa é um animal racional e
pois obviamente continua a dizer que
respira que vai pro trabalho lê e
escreve que o filho brinca constrói que
falta fazer
mas o penico a ginástica guardas enfim o
joão mata com eu faço tudo diz a maria
que é uma mulher e portanto muito mais
pragmática muito mais concreta e com
cinta acha pura e simplesmente que o ser
humano é uma pessoa e uma pessoa é um
ser humano é minha irmã que está em algo
de que me empenharei vai ficar um crente
que ela deve ser usada inclusive acha
que o ser humano é um conjunto sem
correr aqui as minhas notas que o ser
humano é um corpo cheio de sonhos dos
perus e visões que procuram
incessantemente a felicidade
o paulo acho que o ser humano é um
conjunto de falhas que juntas formam uma
unidade feita essa ordem de som revelado
é que as demissões foram muitas e é o
que eu entendi nesta pesquisa muito
rápida e que toda a gente me pede o ser
humano enquanto eu o ser humano enquanto
aspecto comunitário o ser humano
enquanto busca da felicidade a parte
racional como é óbvio que nós já todos
sabemos que o distingue dos outros dias
mas não há nunca ser humano acontecer
tecnológico é claramente nós mil novos a
tecnologia nós somos daqueles que acham
que as crianças bilhões só para a rua
brincar mais com os outros que seu
tablet computador em casa até porque
todos sabemos que nosso tempo as coisas
não eram nada assim eram 500
mas então vamos tentar entender um trem
no qual é o papel de alta tecnologia nas
nossas vidas ea tecnologia têm vindo a
ser desenvolvido ao longo do tempo
sobretudo para nos facilitar as nossas
tarefas do dia a dia para nos libertar
tempo e vamos criar uma certa autonomia
faça as coisas que temos que fazer e
hoje em dia a tecnologia tem papel um
caso em francisco
a tecnologia hoje passar o parte do
nosso tempo e passa muitas vezes a ser
associado a produtos ou serviços que são
por um lado o clube com os por outros
médicos por exemplo de monitorização é
verdade é que seja produtivo com o outro
nós acabamos por nos associar a
tecnologia e por muitas vezes depender
delas da tecnologia e é nesse processo
nós todos podemos usar essa um
microondas trajeto visão seja osmar pode
estar já for a verdade é que eu estava
é muito grande inclusive nos grandes
eventos das nossas vidas quer que nunca
fez a famosa self no casamento e um
batizado
e por isso mesmo podemos protelar móvel
o telemóvel por exemplo é um conjunto de
aplicações sem fim é por um lado a nossa
melhor amiga que os descontos que eu sei
que nós temos que provar que temos que o
ginásio e chris dizem que vão fazer e eu
falo com conhecimento de causa oficial
do amor uma dessas aplicações e como
devem imaginar ela estava
sistematicamente pichada dizer que o
dinheiro primeiro pra ver se ganham com
percentual
mas ele também é parte de um enfermeiro
que não utilizam o sono por exemplo que
se nós funcionamos nós temos a platéia é
parte do nosso ponto de vista que nos
vai dizendo que não temos que estar mais
nesse mês e é também por exemplo um guia
para nós nos colocaram em trajetos por
exemplo dentro de uma cidade o que
melhora muito em cima vida dos homens de
exclusão tabu nesta terça feira abrir o
vidro e perguntar a pessoa que está a
passar
onde é que o síndico estamos à procura
de melhor vocês reunião não estava tudo
bem mas a verdade é que eu não sou assim
tão dependente quanto isso de tecnologia
cai então vamos ver o que nos acontece
por exemplo quanto estamos faça um
momento de perigo
o momento do problema e meninos e vamos
concentrar num problema prisão com os
refugiados toda a gente sabe que os
refugiados têm sido um problema série e
um problema identificado mundo e eu não
sei se vocês lembram um projeto que
surgiu a se adaptando os refugiados que
o time beque não se lembra mas
basicamente este projeto fazia futura
fava o seu - que cada refugiado vaga na
sua mala quando a partida e é uma coisa
muito simples vez em que telemóveis os
perdedores eram dois dos objetos mais
utilizados
aquando da fuga e 5 explicar é que na
verdade nós todos estamos de tal maneira
conectados que queremos estar conectados
com o mundo seja obtendo um homem do
outro lado do mundo e queremos estar
sempre a falar com ela seja porque
queremos assumir 15 minutos mas a
verdade é que também nos liga uma outra
realidade outro lado do espelho que é o
nosso eu virtual
nós todos somos um carinho assim sempre
estamos desta coisa é verdade é que
todos temos um chamado de tinta ou ruim
11 min digital que vai marcando a nossa
vida e vai deixando dados online sobre o
nosso discurso estes dados são guardados
num qualquer servidor o qual nós não
temos acesso
nós sabemos que o facebook venceram uma
vez que uma vez em quase todos os
grandes de ter ferido aquela coisa de
dizer que não sabe mas há dois anos
tivessem city com esta pessoa que eu
tenho para nos lembrar seja coisas boas
e coisas más e ver daqui 90 uma questão
será que nós enquanto seres humanos
conseguimos iniciar a nossa componente
digital
mas o ser humano não não passas o
contato com tecnologia e ambiente urbano
um contato a conhecer face com ele mas
outros elementos que com os pais têm que
lidar no dia-a-dia em deus é o carro e
nós todos sabemos que o mais importante
no carro é o motor são os cavalos e toda
a estrutura estava no carro e sabemos
também que o carro nos representar no
início do século 20 como uma mal como
uma máquina altamente competente que nos
podem transportar em família que depois
dessa incluir os seus modelos para o
transporte por exemplo mais férias com
ônibus um certo a famosa conforma e ao
longo do tempo nós vamos tendo a vamos
adaptando um carro passa a ser não só um
objetivo no ano passado muitas vezes são
histórias moda e passa a ser sobretudo
status social e o carro que então se
muitas vezes o caso o ar condicionado os
vidros elétricos enfim o gps as câmeras
tudo que aí possamos do conceito à
realidade como foi dito antes jogar fato
hoje em dia é um computador é um
smartphone sobre rodas
a verdade é que nós não sei se vocês já
tiveram a já viram alguns dos vídeos que
estão colocados online sobre as
experiências foram feitas com com
transportes autônomos com veículos
autônomos sejam as pessoas a entrar no
veículo inicialmente um quê de
repreensível do armamento com arroz
anguita vamos pois acham acham
interessantes a viagem censuras e agora
como estão e quando o carro tivesse de
ir quando ao acidente
qual é o melhor recurso e qual é o
número de vítimas
nós queremos a campinense por nós nós
temos de fato a confiança no carro tem
conhecer sua mãe
nós tivemos por exemplo tirar a carta
condição hoje em dia ser autônomo nós
temos com para ter a noite sem ter os
pais a perna ainda por cima tivemos a
sorte de ter os primeiros é um dos
primeiros a ter o carro a carta quais
são os problemas e segundo nosso
o domingo também para serem decisões
frisou que não tem nada a ver com isso
só que a verdade é que hoje em dia e os
filmes já vieram dizer provavelmente as
crianças que nasceu em 2007 já nunca vão
ter condições e portanto como era feito
antes fato isso é uma realidade
agora temos de novo a questão das
cidades e dos pacientes o que consegue o
que é realidade
a cidade inclusive nós somos
bombardeados com um sem-número de
estatísticas e outro só que algumas nós
sabemos que provavelmente a partir de
2050 nós tivemos mais de 75 setenta
população mundial viverá em cidades e
também sabemos na questão da
sustentabilidade para viver segundo os
padrões europeus de vida 30 até apenas
consultoria 2 milhões de pessoas o que
quer dizer claramente que nós
precisaremos de por outros planetas para
poder ser sustentados e isto vai ter
várias questões são que nem assustadores
mas levanta várias questões com essas
cidades têm pensado em mim o governo
está implementado portanto tem tentado
criar um dos caminhos que sejam
alternativos de cliente faz uma função
eficácia este problemas e portanto das
cidades querem claramente tornar simples
gente mas sim à tecnologia nos traz
por um lado uma série de ferramentas que
são extremamente úteis para nós podemos
gerir a cidade projetá lo assim enfim e
ter uma utilização concreta das tiradas
de lado e por outro lado que aconteceu é
que nós acabamos por perder muitas das
ligações que temos e tradicionalmente
eram muito importante para a coesão
social e para o mal estar social e nesse
sentido importa o que importa é a que
nós entendemos muito o que é este
conceito das funções inconsciente em
quais são as funções e inteligência
aplicadas a vida do nosso dia a dia do
evento a agência que não estamos a falar
muitas vezes estamos a falar apenas de
inteligência computacional e nós
percebemos que já faz assim impedindo
aquela onda dos anos 90 em todas as
cidades imaginavam ser pura e
simplesmente com quadras de robôs em
câmeras e quase que a gente não tomar
todas as decisões por nós porque nós
tivemos lá vão sair daquilo que foi
integrada ou seja porque nós percebemos
que as soluções não funcionam
é a verdade é que diz com sopros metal
com vinhos a pouco essas cidades não
podem associar-se das duas componentes
que tem é virtual e humano e isso faz
com que nós entendamos claramente que a
cidade não é só um algoritmo abstrato a
cidade só faz sentido a partir do
momento em que a materialidade ea
vivenciada por todos nós
nesse sentido porque nós então
continuamos associar a cidade ea
inteligência desconhecia inteligência da
cidade
só a inteligência computacional quando
nós temos não só inteligência que já
falou à inteligência individual mas
felizmente gc coletiva e temos muitas
vezes emocional e que não tem nenhuma
piscina sabemos que em inovação que é um
fator essencial para a cidade do futuro
só senti me só acontece quando há uma
uma fronteira entre as várias
disciplinas importante quando a
tecnologia e se junta ao espaço social
espaço artístico aos paciente fique
todas elas trabalham num com o objetivo
é criar inovação e rita chaves aqui
alguns conceitos que parecem essenciais
para a cidade do futuro e com base
nalguns nalguns projectos depois van
estão disponíveis pra vocês procurarem
mais a bola é que esta cidade do futuro
é uma cidade que tem que ter em atenção
os dados e tem que ter em atenção os
dados numa perspectiva muito concreta de
saber o seu passado e seu presente na
sociedade não tem que recolher os dados
só forma digital pode escolher os forma
analógica e sobretudo deve utilizar
estes dados para conseguir tomar
decisões para o futuro
e estes dados realmente devem ser
disponibilizados para todos os cidadãos
nomeadamente os nível após possam ter a
terceira ou criar novas funções e do que
o tempo do projeto recreativo em que
este ano a eleição está neste momento em
várias cidades do mundo e é verdade que
o requisite vita estágio com os dados
das várias cidades em melhorá los
uma senhora também uma cidade do futuro
é também aquela que pega nos seus
cidadãos e os escuta e dialoga com isso
de uma forma transparente muito bem
também sobre o porquê das suas
ferramentas ajustes cidades ea realidade
dos cidadãos e vocês podem ver aqui que
nós usamos um projeto que é o projeto
meu bairro que em várias cidades a nível
a nível europeu a usamos alta tecnologia
para recolher os dados dos cidadãos a
verdade é que a maior parte das pessoas
não possuindo assim bastou chegar com
maior dose com jeans e nós conseguimos
fazer um processo de escolha às
necessidades muito mais valor da as
cidades do futuro são também aquelas que
entendem que a comunidade deve ser visto
ou siga e as relações sociais têm ser
estimuladas e portanto temos aqui um
exemplo de um projeto que eu vi roubar
que dava que percebeu isso e que tenta
reunir gerações e várias pessoas tanto
da comunidade dos bairros como no seu
contacto com a realidade exterior que é
da china mas uma cidade e também da
cidade do futuro e também aquela que
aposta na subversão aberta e
transparente como já alguém se machuca
tudo para criar serviços e junta se a
todos os atores da cidade eo elemento em
última análise aos seus utilizadores que
são o foco do serviço na cidade e que
estimula tanto o desenvolvimento
econômico com o seu ecossistema de
inovação é que temos um exemplo por
exemplo do caso do porto e do projecto
português vai assinar e pra finalizar no
fundo há uma mensagem que eu acho que é
essencial à cidade do futuro é tão
simplesmente aquela que valoriza a
qualidade de vida do cidadão janeiro o
trabalho seja a nível de saúde a nível
da habitação seja a nível cultural
artístico é verdade é que a cidade do
futuro só pode ser uma
aquela que é inteligente e humana
obrigado
[Aplausos]